hi everyone I'm Ilana and today we're
talking about fake news and the death of
journalism and the notion that
journalists in general can't be trusted
anymore and how dangerous I think that
is this is gonna get very political and
kind of ranty so if you don't want to
see that just tap out now there are bad
journalists there are people who report
unverified news as fact many outlets
have reported false things about me
personally I absolutely know how it
feels to be dragged through the door in
the interest of getting clicks on an
incorrect headline there are outlets
that have been proven to be manipulated
by money or political influence and I
absolutely believe those outlets should
be held accountable
they should be confronted wherever
possible and we should be making every
effort to correct these issues rather
than just sending a million angry tweets
because we need them we need good
political journalism and not all
journalists are corrupt because if they
were there wouldn't be documented
examples of governments trying to
silence dismiss and shut down
journalistic outlets since the 1700s
even on things that were proven true
both the left and right sides of
government are hugely benefited every
time someone says they don't trust
journalists because they don't want you
to and with that journalists who are
often also referred to as the Fourth
Estate which is something I encourage
you to look up if you want already
familiar with the time have been
credited for ushering and democracy and
preventing tyranny historically on many
many different occasions and the
importance of press in a representative
democracy or even in a modern
constitutional monarchy is twofold
someone has to stand between the state
and the people to inform those people
because democracy cannot function
without informed citizens and you can
never trust the state to provide you
with objectivity of again especially
considering how much power they have
trusting the government to accurately
inform you on everything that I doing is
basically like giving up your vote so
that's what journalists are for ideally
a trained group of people who were
taught to cut through political
marketing and find a fact to report
citizens but also to serve as a feedback
loop between the government and voters
taking the citizens questions and
presenting them to politicians no matter
how controversial they might be if you
cut out the journalists all of your
world news everything you know comes
from the government with no
accountability and there is no freedom
in that now you should already know that
I'm not telling you to a completely
trust press because you should
absolutely not do that but the art of
unique outlets with different political
stance
and a different wealth of resources that
using your free access to those you
should be able to come to a conclusion
that is much more objective than
anything the government will say to you
that's why there's also a responsibility
on citizens to verify most of you aren't
stupid I hope most of you aren't too
lazy and the press can't always allocate
to the lowest common denominator either
learning to read press correctly is just
so important to political conversation
and I swear that the way to do this
should be taught in schools from the
youngest age possible everyone should
know to read a quote like these reports
allege as this thing says and not this
thing is true that phrasing isn't even
manipulative either they're not trying
to trick you anything something is true
it's just the most concise communication
of the information and sometimes
journalists aren't able to verify things
the government says because there's so
much secrecy and dishonesty and I don't
think that should mean that journalists
can't write about things they should
just be very very clear when something
is not confirmed with that I think
citizens owe it to their countries to
read multiple news sources never just a
headline and also read them literally
without Gemina conclusions read the ones
you don't agree with read the ones you
do agree with the question both don't
dismiss an entire site because you don't
like one article or one writer and don't
only rate the mainstream if you only
read things aligned with your political
view or support your party of choice you
effectively devalue your own vote and
your own intelligence if you argue with
everyone who has a different political
stance to you calling them a sexist and
a racist or on the other side calling
them an sjw or a Lib Todd you devalue
you but now I'm not trying to say we
have a tyranny on our hands every time a
person in politics calls out a media
outlet for reporting something that's
unverified as fact but you are too smart
to dismiss every single journalist
involved in political journalism because
of it freedom of press guarantees
popular participation in the decisions
of the government and popular
participation is the pinnacle of
democracy so with that the government
should never be allowed to pick which
expressions or outlets to authorize and
which to prevent and for those of you
who made it this far thank you I try to
talk about politics often but I did
write an essay about this as far back as
2013 when I was studying political
journalism I just really believe
that the citizens and the journalists
should be allies in holding the
government accountable always thank you
guys for watching I'll see you next time